mais pour l'heure on va revenir sur les
simpson mais il faut laisser ça par
coeur série qui date depuis maintenant
près de 30 ans pas en trente ans c'est
énorme
et visiblement les prédictions alors on
s'est intéressé à l'ensemble de tout ce
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont annoncés ont tous
les cas qu'ils ont racontées avant que
cela n'arrive et le créateur avait
déclaré on prend l'événement le plus
improbable
le plus ridicule le plus stupide et
quelque chose d'impossible qui
n'arrivera jamais or on pas pourquoi
parce qu'ils avaient prédit le corno
coronavirus c'est pourquoi comme la
bière virus non merci ou l'achat
l'unique c'est donc ça c'est ce qu'il
avait déclaré le créateur de de la non
télé c'est oui c'est ce que je suis en
direct
voilà dix ans qu'il avait donc prévu le
fameux virus alors devant une petite
image qui prouve sa ba 93 voilà sauf
qu'il venait du japon voilà il est du
japon s'est fait voilà qu'en mai ensuite
en 2020 on sait ce qui peut arriver
en 2000 vous rendez compte en 2000 en
2015 élection du président le 11
septembre devant plus fort 97
voilà 2001 on sait ce qui arrive est
alors s'est lâché sur leur but ryan
attend ça me fait flipper mois comme en
occident 2013 17la monde connecté il
l'avait annoncé en 95 arriver en 2014
ces éléments bien évidemment le plus
d'ennemis dramatique d'ebola était
annoncé en 97 et qui arrivera en 2014
allusion il ya d'ailleurs une autre une
autre série jouanno décennie qui avait
annoncé l'accident d'hélicoptère
complètement de été dessinées à l'école
quoi alors sais pas si c'est un hasard
7 / de la société américaine et les
mêmes d'associer des mondiale les
auteurs ont la capacité de prédire
finalement ce qui peut arriver mais
c'est vrai que c'est assez troublant
il faut savoir que cette série a été
renouvelée jusqu'en 2000 80 2 par la fox
2082 ils ont les droits de diffusion 82
on verrait pas la fin
j'ai bien cool je te les faire la mettre
en mouvement et pour vous alors vous
donc le big c
[Applaudissements]
et on aime ça finira par y voir la fin
de la saison des achats dans lesquels en
flux non je rigole